this is what Beijing looked like some 20
years ago China then was called the
kingdom of bicycles but then planners
had a different idea for decades they
did everything they could to make
Beijing more car friendly around six
million vehicles now clogged its roads
and highways and the kingdom of bicycles
has become the capitol of traffic jams
then two years ago colourful rental
bikes suddenly began appearing
everywhere all you need to use one
briefly is the app and they cost less
than 30 Euro cents per hour so anyone
with a smartphone can now find the bike
practically anywhere I went to find out
if the new technology is encouraging
people to get out of their cars more
bike was the first bike sharing company
it launched in 2016 and now claims to
have 200 million users worldwide at
first there was cutthroat competition
there were over a hundred companies on
the market now there are just three or
four left you're not making a profit yet
but we're getting there bit by bit our
results in September were
extraordinarily good I can tell you that
much how would I be able to locate
someone I'll be back
one of my first questions how much are
the rental bikes really being used
so when do you rent a bicycle
well if I don't have to go more than 20
kilometres number that far most Beijing
residents use the bikes for much shorter
distances for the so called last mile
from the subway to their office or home
for the first time in quite a while
the number of bike journeys is growing
Sandra Reza advises the Chinese Ministry
of Transport on behalf of the German
government
thus far in vitam that was the positive
effect of all the various bike sharing
companies officials started rethinking
things in the cities and in said
government it's a big discussion in many
urban areas today all over the world the
question of how we can get people to
enjoy riding bikes
most roads in Beijing have a bike lane
like this and we are going to take a
look now in what condition they are this
one is nice and wide and pretty
comfortable to ride on even if there are
a couple of obstacles along the way I
just managed to squeeze past one car
making a turn and there's another issue
too many vehicles stop or Park on the
bike path then you have to swerve into
the car lane so a less than perfect
situation
and there are other negative aspects to
bike-sharing like the numbers of rental
bikes cluttering up streets and
sidewalks or authorities now often just
pile them up onto what look like scrap
heaps the bikes the city administration
has cleared are now unloaded here on the
fringes of the capital every major
Chinese city has bicycle cemeteries like
this one
the remaining rental companies have to
take back some of them nobody knows what
will happen to the rest Moe bike is
grappling with new regulations for bike
sharing in this city 750,000 of its
bikes can be found on the streets of
Beijing the government won't allow them
to deploy more on peak days their bikes
can rack up to million trips I think
many new business models need a phase of
irrational competition but in the future
this industry will become extremely
environmentally friendly and sustainable
every ride is recorded by the system mo
bike not only knows how many of its
bikes are being used it also has to be
able to tell at a given moment where
each is located
all rental bicycle companies now have to
install live monitoring systems the data
from them is also transmitted in tandem
to the government but people like mr.
doom are even more important he collects
scattered rental bikes driving around
the streets of cheong wantin where page
ings young IT industry is located and
loading them up mr. dong brings them
back to places where they're needed like
subway stations John Watson sees many
young commuters and the subway is the
hotspot for bike sharing the by
collector came to Beijing from his
village just a year ago he gets paid by
the day for his labor in a month he can
earn about 600 euros that's about half
the average wage 9:00 in the morning is
the busiest time by then everyone is in
their offices the bikes are all over the
place I fill up my truck every few
minutes our rental bikes really the
solution to Beijing's traffic problems
to find out more I take a detour in the
historic district as the city modernized
the old town became a symbol for
backwardness for the old and the poor
who lived here bicycles were a common
means of transport today the charms of
the old town are being rediscovered by
young people and what about bikes this
small shop wants to show the people of
Beijing that cycling can be fun
customers can design their own bikes
here you can take any color you want you
can see which one you like
now Hanoi highlights it goes on that
some customers rediscover cycling
through riding rental bikes they use
them but they don't find them
comfortable enough they're too small
they don't have enough gears or only
suitable for short distances and many
rental bikes are in bad condition and
are poorly maintained after riding water
until bikes however people decide they
want to buy one of their
and slowly but surely the bicycle
culture is reimbursing so bike sharing
has acted as a catalyst helping Beijing
residents rediscover an important means
of transport from the past now all
that's needed is a sustainable plan for
the traffic of the future
[Music]
you